[Music]
you're on America's Got tonight that's
got to be a tough gig because you live
here in Los Angeles but you have to do
the show in New York you're flying like
crazy I just flew in we just flew in
just that I flew in now we were we're
actually started this season at the airs
May 27th but we started this season in
New York you know it's weird about the
flying is cuz they ask questions and I
don't know I don't
okay I was flying today right and the
flight attendant walked to my seat and
she said to me she asked me will I be
joining will you be joining us for lunch
that's what she said to me right how can
I have other plans where am I gonna go
she said will you be joining us for
lunch no I mean can you give me
directions to some other how could i
yeah everyone's joining you for lunch I
will be part of the say no parachute no
we're not only doing a GTR yeah I'm
doing a lot of off-broadway in fact
everything I'm doing from now on is
off-broadway no yes
why is that I didn't know because I'm
not on Broadway technically off Broadway
right yeah this show is off Broadway oh
you betcha yes I have a question yeah
you get a as part of your work yes
regular thing where you get makeup
applied right wearing it now I don't
normally look like this yeah you look
like if I don't realize that I am a
young asian girl
very attractive one by the way too
here's the thing yes I know that you are
very conscious of germs that's why you
like people to fist bump you how do you
deal with people touching your face and
the makeup that must mean crazy
you might hear funny story no no you
tell us the truth is I have it Wendy's
back there she's I have like a makeup
artist that I know is hermetically
sealed and clean but I can't always take
I'm not I can't take Wendy with me right
so what I'm strange so there is I guess
my my reputation precedes me and people
like I'll show up someplace and they'll
have like Purell and they have like
wipes and and everything so I was in New
York just recently and the girl had like
gloves she had like surgical gloves in
Purell and I go it's really not
necessary you don't have to wear the
gloves as long as you wash your hand
I mean it's crazy I'm okay with just
your regular hand she goes you have no
problem with that I said no no I have no
problem this is not a joke she she opens
up the makeup and she goes like this in
the makeup and then she starts doing
this on my face that's I meant the I
thought that she would use a brush yeah
who does that it was like she's putting
makeup on me like this she said the
four-year-old child oh wait
there's such an amazing ending wait till
you hear the ending of this story I and
this okay so she's rubbing my face and I
go like I meant I thought you were gonna
use a brush the problem is I'm looking
at mine I look at you I can see over my
shoulder and this guy's holding up a
sign that says 90 seconds there's only
like that you know but the thing is the
best part of this story happens in like
two minutes from now
I don't wanna I don't wanna I don't know
I'm telling this story no but oh now
look what happened look at that is only
a minute don't worry about it no I can't
because it's going to leave people
they're gonna go well there's no ending
no no no I didn't you asked me the
question too late in the interview and I
don't have time you just spent three
minutes talking about this but this is
it is there a minute oh there's only 30
I can't believe you touch this I know
where this thing's been what that's you
don't want to know where he keeps this
thing we all got in use all right look
you got your time pal how come you don't
have like a digital thing where is this
that you're this was a home project when
you were four you can just do this three
to one can afford a long time you know
what forget the story for II go to
commercial I don't wanna I don't wanna
tell a story go to a commercial go to a
commercial rack after this be back with
more
[Applause]